[Music]
in the mid-1970s
after decades of political turmoil
greece
finally seemed to be on the path to
stability with the introduction of a new
constitution
and negotiations underway to enter
european institutions
many analysts expected greek politics to
follow the pattern
of the larger western world then in 1981
a political party called passock came to
power
its charismatic leader andreas
papandreyou
railed against the new constitution and
accused those in power
of national betrayal opposing greece's
membership in nato
and the european economic community
papantreju promised to govern
for the betterment of the common people
above all
else he famously declared there are no
institutions
only the people exist papandreou's rise
to power
isn't a unique story in many democratic
countries around the world
charismatic leaders vilify political
opponents
disparage institutions and claim the
mantle
of the people some critics label this
approach as authoritarian or
fascist and many argue that these
leaders are using emotions to manipulate
and deceive
voters but whether or not this style of
politics is ethical
it's certainly democratic and it goes by
the name
of populism the term populism has been
around since ancient rome
and has its roots in the latin word
papulus meaning
the people but since then populism has
been used to describe
dozens of political movements often with
counter-intuitive and sometimes
contradictory goals
populist movements have rebelled against
monarchies monopolies
and a wide variety of powerful
institutions
it's not possible to cover the full
history of this term here
instead we're focusing on one specific
type of populism
the kind that describes papandreya's
administration and numerous other
governments
over the last 70 years modern populism
but to understand how political
theorists define this phenomenon
we first need to explore what it's
responding to
in the aftermath of world war ii many
countries wanted to move
away from totalitarian ideologies they
sought a new political system that
prioritized individual and social rights
aimed at political consensus and
respected the rule of law
as a result most western nations adopted
a long-standing form of government
called liberal democracy in this context
liberal doesn't refer to any political
party but rather a type of democracy
that has three essential components
first
liberal democracies accept that society
is full of many
often cross-cutting divisions that
generate conflict
second it requires that society's many
factions
seek common ground across those
divisions
finally liberal democracies rely on the
rule of law
and the protection of minority rights as
specified in constitutions and legal
statutes
taken together these ideals propose that
tolerance
and institutions that protect us from
intolerance
are the bedrock of a functional and
diverse democratic society
liberal democracies helped bring
stability to the nations that adopted
them
but like any system of government they
didn't solve
everything among other issues an
ever-increasing wealth gap
led to under-served communities who
distrusted both their wealthy neighbors
and their political leaders in some
cases
political corruption further damaged the
public's trust
growing suspicion and resentment around
these politicians
primed citizens to look for a new kind
of leader
who would challenge established
institutions and put the needs of the
people
first in many ways this reaction
highlights democracy
in action if the majority of a
population feels their interests are
underrepresented they can elect leaders
to change that
using existing democratic systems but
this is where assertive
modern populist candidates can subvert
democracy
modern populists identify themselves as
embodying the will
of the people and they place those
interests
above the institutions that protect
individual
and social rights modern populists argue
these institutions are run by a
self-serving
ruling minority who seek to control the
vast majority of virtuous common people
as a result politics is no longer about
seeking compromise and consensus
through tolerant democratic institutions
instead
these leaders seek to overturn what they
see
as a broken system this means that where
a liberal democracy has the utmost
respect for institutions like courtrooms
free press and national constitutions
modern populists
disparage any establishment that
disagrees with the so-called
common will modern populist parties have
arisen in many places
but the leaders of these movements are
remarkably similar
they're often charismatic individuals
who identify themselves as
embodying the will of the people they
make
exorbitant promises to their supporters
while casting their opponents
as traitors actively undermining the
country
but whether these politicians are
sincere believers or manipulative
opportunists
the dynamics they unleash can be
profoundly destabilizing
for liberal democracy even when modern
populist leaders
don't follow through with their most
extreme promises
their impact on political discourse the
rule of law
and public trust can long outlast their
time in office
how well do you understand power it
shapes our daily lives but we're often
uncomfortable talking about it
learn about the six sources of power and
the key to being an effective citizen
with this lesson